oberst klaus schaden bauer ist seit 15
dezember 21 der nationalen kontingents
kommandant für alle österreichischen
soldaten in der eu geführten european
junior training mission in mali der
geborene wiener absolvierte den 19
generalstabs kurs und war bereits bei
mehreren auslandsmissionen im einsatz
ich bin der nationalen kontingents
kommandant und damit vorgesetzter aller
österreichischen soldaten bei rtl ii
diese soldaten sind stationiert in
bamako im hauptquartier hier im kolleg
und colo colo training center und in see
wo wir auch eine ausbildungseinheit
haben insgesamt haben wir derzeit 80
soldaten immerhin zu sagen
ich bin auch der kommandant der
education and training chaos kurs in der
mission diese task force ist zuständig
für die ausbildung der malischen
streitkräfte man kann sagen sie ist das
kernelement von geothermalen in dieser
funktion habe ich zur verfügung einen
beraterstab und ausbilder aus 20
nationen und circa 150 soldatinnen und
soldaten aus ganz europa mache diesen
auftrag
als kommandant der tdf bin ich
gleichzeitig hier der kasernenkommandant
kurz der kette sie commander vom kolleg
und trainingscenter das ist eine sehr
spezielle funktion denn hier muss ich
sehr eng mit den malischen streit recht
auf leben die im selben lager steen
zusammenarbeiten mein ansprechpartner
ist dabei etwas traurig mit ihm muss ich
auf täglicher basis eigentliche leben
hier organisieren das umfasst vor allem
das wichtigstes element die militärische
sicherheit für alle soldaten aber auch
alle anderen bereiche des täglichen
lebens vor der versorgung über die
unterkunft bis hin zu die kommunikation
mit den kindern
was tun sie denn
[Musik]
im rahmen des festaktes zur parade in
curicó anlässlich des 61 jahrestages der
malische armee wird ihm die ehrenvolle
aufgabe übertragen der witwe eines im
einsatz gefallenen malischen soldaten
die malische ehrenmedaille zu
überreichen es ist natürlich schwierig
in solchen momenten die richtigen worte
zu finden aber ich habe ja gesagt dass
diese medaille ein ein sichtbares
zeichen dafür ist dass das opfer ihres
mannes nie vergessen sein wird